the idea of the mixtape is actually
rather astounding for in the act of
making a mixtape
we are creatively and discriminating ly
deciding who we are and who we aren't in
the choices of song that we choose to
include in a playlist
we are authoring states of being that we
will then inhabit we are screenwriting
the evanescent flux of sensation and
perception that Eric Davis says is all
we have and all we are with our musical
choices we author interior States
landscapes of mind can be structured and
patterned with our musical choices we
are all the creative DJ's of our own
experience and we must realize that then
our choices govern our fate our musical
choices literally are like paintbrushes
in the
work of art that is our lives for in the
words of jean-paul sartre everything has
been figured out except how to live
because again our lives exist in
individual moments and it is up to us to
make sure those moments are vital
interconnected and grand how do we make
of our lives moments that are vital
interconnected and grand we make a
mixtape we live by it
we-we've song into our daily reveries we
impregnate the mundane with song we set
the world on fire we use it we use
melody to make sense of our troubles and
find joy in the everyday the director
Cameron Crowe once said that making a
movie the ordeal of making a motion
picture was just an excuse to get into
the editing room with his music
supervisor and setting the movie to
music watching the movie actually come
alive actually start to make sense when
set to a soundtrack and what is a
soundtrack in a film except for a
brilliantly executed mixtape where the
right song comes on at just the right
moment
and like a miracle I want to do
everything right here
what a beautiful feeling
[Music]
the most meaningful moments of our lives
are defined by the right song
clicking playing at just the right
moment bookmarking said a moment into
the repository of our lives marking the
spot x marks the spot that moment that
song changed my life I kissed the girl
I said yes I overcame I triumph I
surrendered I let it all go I lost
myself and found myself in song
[Music]
and knowing knowing that we have the
agency to create the soundtrack of our
lives should give us a dizzying amount
of freedom and empowerment for we are
not the victims of happenstance of
circumstance no we are playwrights we
are poets we are music makers and
dreamers of dreams we set our lives and
live our lives by song and this will
make all the difference but take the
road less traveled by
that will make all
so let us end then
by paying reverence to the power of
music or without music life would be a
mistake